he's number six the numbers a B cough
which is a bit more today but that's not
necessarily a bad thing I want to get my
pair of numbers that add to something
they multiply to something what are they
going to add to this particular question
yeah the app negative 19 there we go
there's that number in the middle and
the pair of numbers want to multiply to
66 times ten okay now when you have a
look at this 60s of being uh but it's
got lots of factors but you can round it
down when you see this - design team
right it looks to me like this is going
to be two negative numbers because
they've got a multiply be positive but
somehow they're gonna have to be dated
so what two negatives did you think of
yeah for now I'll just pause for a
second and just make a side comment
which I'll address again in a few
minutes if you were like mitt where are
these numbers coming from I gave it just
like coming out of thin air you're right
this is not easy right which is why
mathematicians look this probably
thought there's got to be another way to
do this okay so we will get to another
one in a minute for now let's see we can
do with these numbers now that we know
what they are the reason I've got these
is because I'm going to break apart this
- 19 X into a minus 15 and a minus 4
okay so I'm going to tease it apart like
that my question will be all right which
one should I put first which one do I
want to pair with this guy and which one
do I one pair with this guy okay
what are you guys record do you think
for example the 15 the minus 15 X plug
rather rescue
do you think it should go with the 10x
squared or with the 6
I reckon probably with the take squared
right and easy it doesn't always work
but an easy way to notice is that if
you've got a big number in a small
number usually the big number I'm going
to the big one and this more one will go
with the small one usually okay so let's
write this out I'm gonna break apart
that - 19 X now there's my minus 4 X
plus 6 and now is the moment of truth
I'm going to look at those two pairs one
two and when I take out whatever factor
I can from there I look the same thing
happening for both of them like this X
plus 4 that we got before
all right if I get the safety then I
know I'm on the right track what can I
take out of the first pair I can take
out five eggs right ten and fifteen now
give me five and you'll you'll notice is
happening over never again right because
of the way we pin you'll always be able
to get one x at the first pair so I take
my 5 X out which leaves me with 3x take
away 3 okay now this is promising
because when you look at this it looks
like it's going to work out what should
I take out of the second pair okay then
watch out is it interesting what you
should take out maybe of to the reason
why you want to take out negative is
because CNAs is minus 3 key you want
there to be a minus 3 at the end but
that's positive then something have to
take out a negative that sure enough
gives me 2x minus 3 okay and you can
just double-check mentally if you went
backwards minus 2x sorry minus 2 times
2x thank you for that minus 2 times
minus 3 then double negative cancels and
gives you the plus 6 thumbs up so that
equals 0 now I've got my two pairs and I
can finish off my factorization okay
what do i do from here now that I
actually impacted
I want to find it I'm up it's gonna make
that zero I don't want to find out about
that the exact zero if you like you go
through this whole process and write the
equations out but you start to get
familiar enough with these that off the
first one Fritz's I can say see how I'm
going to multiply by five right five
times that number I want this to be
something over five so the fives cancel
what over five it's going to be the
other number so that they'll collapse
together a be 0 so 2 over 5 is one of my
solutions and the other one here / -
then have a three left over it'll be
three of its okay
last ones have crack at it
8x squared minus 2x minus 3 let's see if
we can do this one in a case without
writing down the extra step I'm
searching for a pair of numbers I want
them to add two minus two and what doll
of them to multiply by negative 24 minus
8 times 18 all right so I want numbers
that are off by 2 and they multiply to
24 minus 24 okay which factors am I
gonna look for now you're 6 and plus 4
that's going to do it for years ago so
this minus 2x I'm gonna prank break
apart into a minus 6 X and a plus 4x
right which one should be which which
one should go first before X this is an
interesting one remember how I said
usually big numbers go in big numbers
they don't always in every single time
if I write out a x squared plus 4x you
can see these guys have a lot in common
right and then I'm going to write my
minus 6 X minus 3 along the end okay now
I can pair up
let C be 4x
is that all right what I'll take out of
the second thing and there's my same
factor on both of them and now I'm
pretty much there okay again I'm gonna
read my numbers off I would a multiply
by 4 so my number will be divided by 4 I
don't want to be left with a 3 and with
this one I'm gonna multiply by 2 so I
want it to be divided by 2 and why is it
negative why is it they give this time
exact a plus here right so I actually
want this number to be minus 1 so when
it hits the plus 1 it vanishes away